what are the odds we ever get to see a
brick and mortar ymh comedy club uh I
don't think we would we would get into
that business um mostly just because I'm
not interested in in running my own
Comedy Club I think it's great that
Austin offers what it offers you know
Joe has the mothership there's Creek in
the cave red band has the the the sunset
room whatever it's called there's the
the new Cap City at the Domain so you
have all these places I I don't want to
be involved in owning a comedy club I'm
much more interested in having like a
bakery or something like that has
nothing to do with that but yeah I'm
super thrilled that Austin is is doing
as well as it is and that comedians all
the time are either moving to Austin or
when I talk to them they're like I'm
thinking about moving to Austin so
obviously like the appeal is there I've
said before if comedy keeps growing like
this it would be cool if six Street in
Austin one day looked like the comedy
version of Nashville Broadway Street
like how every big country singer has
their own bar all the biggest comedians
could have their own clubs all that to
say